one of the hardest gigs I ever had to do
I was in Orlando
Florida and my house was getting
evacuated while I was playing that night
and my wife's like we're evacuated and
my kids are like what do we take and
[__] and I had to go on stage and go hey
like
and my brain was like dude your [__]
house is going to burn down like how can
I go out and rock but I just went out
there and I said to the crowd listen man
my house might burn down during the show
and everybody's
[Laughter]
like [__] you better sing [__]
yeah no cares no but I
said right on well it's time for the
show to
start let's go we are the youth G wild
man let's [__] go and like up there
like you're like I just have insurance
and he's like
[Laughter]
yeah actually what's crazy is that my
house in Jersey that I lost in Hurricane
Irene that happened during a concert
that I was opening for Twisted Sister in
[__] Colorado or something I come off
stage and like like hey man and my house
flooded and like I lost my home during
that concert so that would that would
have been the second
time I was playing on stage in like
Idaho or something it was God Smack
Sebastian B and opening for Twisted
Sister and when I came off there was a
hurricane in Jersey hurricane Irene if
you want to Google watch this Hurricane
Irene Sebastian I want to see some
depressing [__] did it take your house
away or just flooded the watch
this the crowd's cheering as your
[__] house hey man Sebastian loses
home to Hurricane I well they have worse
pictures than that go go back to the
images cuz it shows my house like
[__] underwater and [__] there it is
there's my house underwat there it is
right there well that's different that's
me and the pandemic there it is right
there like so you have to move out right
yes do you have do you get insurance for
that or the government FEMA look at that
that's my [__] house underwater right
there
um God I hate looking at that um how
long were you there for 19 years
man you here is crazy dude okay you see
the water it's like up in my garage
there uh they sent the cop sent
divers into my basement to swim around
and look for dead bodies the whole
basement was under it was
underwater what about your plaqu so then
I moved to California and I get evacu of
fire it's [__] great I Mo from the
flood to the
fire got to Tennessee for the
tornado well you know what's weird about
Vegas it's like hot as hell in the
summer but there's nothing to burn it's
just like a bunch of rocks and dirt yeah
what is a natural disaster here well
your your tires might melt in your car
or something that's it I think that uh
like water shortage yeah that's true
yeah yeah and it's crazy now that like
California is not even like doing
anything for fire
Insurance you can't get fire what's the
story with the fire insurance with the
the par act plan or something it's like
insurance companies are just generally
leaving California Florida as well I
read right so I think the two best
places to move would be Vegas or Ohio I
think is rated the best for climate
change to have the least issues really
but then you got to live in
Ohio yeah um how do you feel about
cryptocurrency I don't know
man I met some guys some guys that hired
me to do a gig and they showed me on
their phone they had like 100 Grand and
[__] and my buddy Matt sorum showed me
on his phone he had like 300 Grand or F
I mean so I have like 200 bucks on there
yeah just to see what what happens to it
I don't really I don't really can you
really spend it anywhere oh yeah yeah
yeah you can certainly are you guys into
it I've been super resistant to it until
last night I had dinner with an old dear
friend of mine who I used to call Billow
I still call him Billow and uh and and
and he finally convinced me he's also um
dying for me to text him a photo of you
and I together losing his mind over how
awesome he thinks no problem my wife
made you guys snacks and [__] how long
you been married uh I've been eight
years eight years yeah and you got kids
yeah how many kids we have uh five
between both of us wow can I ask you a
favor uhuh our buddy Vinnie is getting
married tomorrow what tomorrow you got
any advice for him on a on a beautiful
marriage how long have you known her
almost a year okay and how old are you
36 I'd say do it she's 22 she's 24 24
almost a year that could be wor is March
March of last
year the only thing I would say is that
I got married way too young the first
time and I had no clue no [__] clue
that when like you left your chick you
still had
to I thought I thought you guys aren't
together [__] later nobody even told
me that
ever nobody [__] told me
that still
feeling okay I met a chick when I was 15
and I'm
55 and I'm still giving her [__]
money man is that fair really 15 years
old
55 when does it [__]
end like that's my whole life like child
support or I don't want to get just yeah
money years like is that enough or is it
what like how long does it go like I
mean like holy [__] that is brutal pron
and if somebody says what would you say
like holy [__] dude do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is sto's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and sto's butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude